[Music]
Z
Andy blessed
memory opened up the store be family bre
a blessing on your house and a blessing
on your head meanwhile there's bread to
bake get your T out of
bed go heavy on the B light on the May
for escaping
from finally have a chef worthy of the
name jaob be make himself in the
game I'm in New York on my own but don't
say I'm alone I'm on TV and O found a
nice Jewish boy IA in a spiral my food
Vlogs going viral the bakery is for
loing got a bun in the
oven I really made a killing in the of
never will I set fo again in
DV I got my taxi fixed the insurance
covered it I no longer drive for Uber
I'm now a podiatrist Frank Watcher
hypertension shift it down a gear is
someone actually working I came in for
some shmear
when you
see the
mooning over
the just know I see the moon too and I'm
thinking of
you when you
see the
moon rising over the
angle just know I see the moon too
and I'm
thinking of
you just know I see the
moon and I'm
thinking of
you just no I see the mo to and I'm
[Music]
you